sie fahren gern auf der überholspur
kleintransporter aus osteuropa maximal
3,5 tonnen schwer
eine kleine schlaf zelle auf dem dach
sie befördern das was wir bei ebay und
anderswo im netz bestellen schränke
kisten motorräder werkzeuge es sind so
viele dass spediteure dafür einen namen
erfunden haben polen sprinter ein
autobahnparkplatz bei gelsenkirchen hier
treffen wir jakob soll dann der
polnische fahrer muss hier 48 stunden
rumkriegen bisher in holland neue ware
aufnehmen kann
das leben bei 3 grad am rand der
autobahn hart ja im sommer ist es etwas
besser da können wir uns treffen und
über zu hause reden wir essen und
trinken was zusammen und fühlen uns auch
ein bisschen sicherer
im winter ist es einsam dasteht jeder
allein für sich im warmen wagen
lebensmittel im fußraum oder draußen am
auto alles darf so wenig wie möglich
kosten wochenlang campierte soll dann im
führerhaus schläft in dieser kabine über
dem steuer
60 cm breit genauso hoch und zwei meter
lang ist sein schlafzimmer mein problem
ist dass ich so lange von meiner
freundin getrennt bin ich bin ja
wochenlang unterwegs das ist wirklich
macht soll dann ist einer von vielen die
immer da warten wo sie einen auftrag
ergattern können
der gewerkschafter michael wahl kennt
ihre sorgen sinabell wahl soll
eigentlich lkw fahrer aus osteuropa über
ihre rechte aufklären trifft dabei aber
immer häufiger auf die neuen nomaden des
speditions geschäftes wir beobachten
dass auf manchen rastplätzen zum
beispiel dauerhaft leute stehen die von
diesem rastplatz ihrer tätigkeit ausüben
also die haben gar kein eigenes
natürlich haben die kein eigenes
betriebsgelände oder sonst was die
fahren dann wirklich sobald sie den
auftrag haben sofort los und das ist
sicherlich mehr geworden
über das internet kann jeder die
transporte buchen das versprechen
einfach leicht und billig auf shipley
hätten wir ihnen angebote von über
tausenden zuverlässigen und von kunden
bewerteten transportunternehmen zu
erhalten angebote auf shipley sind
niedrig meist sogar bis zu 75 prozent
günstiger günstig was heißt dass auf der
autobahn
wir stellen einen fiktiven
transportauftrag ins netz zwei paletten
mit maschinenteilen von düsseldorf nach
barcelona
die sollen so schnell wie möglich am
zielort ankommen 1400 kilometer müssen
zurückgelegt werden die fahrer
unterbieten sich der preis für den
transport sinkt von 670 über 566 auf nur
359 euro wir zeigen die angebote dem
gewerkschafter für gerade 359 euro
wollte ein fahrer halb europa
durchqueren mindestens 15 stunden hinter
dem steuer
ja man sieht ja ganz klar hier wird
geboten wie bei ebay sieht man sofort
was der andere angeboten hat den
unterbietet und einer fängt an dann
machen die anderen mit so einfach ist
das mit folgen für die fahrer offen
reden wollen viele nicht und wir drehen
verdeckt
immer mehr fahrer kommen aus der ukraine
moldawien oder weißrussland sie
bräuchten eigentlich ein arbeitsvisum
wer das nicht hat arbeitet oft weit
unter dem deutschen mindestlohn nach
hause fahren ist da über wochen und
monate nicht drin
wir kommen mit den fahrern ins gespräch
einer erklärt warum er ein leben auf der
straße in kauf nimmt
in der ukraine verdiene ich als fahrer
rund 300 euro im monat
und hier hier bekommst du mehr geld hier
in deutschland schaffe ich 2000 euro das
ist für mich wirklich viel geld
die kehrseite einsamkeit
er zeigt uns ein bild seines babys auf
dem handy am wochenende vermisst er
seine familie ganz besonders das warten
ist einfach scheiße scheiße scheiße
es bleibt am samstag nur wodka und bier
die fahrer erzählen sie würden nach
kilometern bezahlt zwischen 26 und
gerade mal sieben cent pro kilometer
wartezeiten ladezeiten stunden im stau
oder ohne auftrag bringt nichts nur wer
schnell und viel fährt kommt über die
runden
eine bezahlung nach kilometern also eine
bezahlung die den fahrer dazu anhält
besonders schnell besonders lange zu
fahren ist verboten
das ist absolut illegal dass es nach eu
recht in ganz europa verboten
horst kopp maja ist spediteur im gehirn
178 lkw seine fahrer müssen strenge
regeln einhalten
wir haben seit vielen jahren in allen
fahrzeugen elektronische tachos der
fahrrad eine digitale fahrerkarte die
jetzt ins gerät geschoben und in dem
moment werden alle bewegungen des
fahrzeugs und tätigkeiten des fahrers
elektronisch erfasst und wie sieht es
bei einem sprinter aus unter dreieinhalb
tonnen gibt es diese geräte sind diese
geräte keine pflicht der fahrer muss nur
eine händische aufzeichnung machen
auf dem formblatt wir nennen das bei uns
so in fachkreisen flügen buch feststeht
kleintransporter waren im vergangenen
jahr 50 prozent häufiger an unfällen
beteiligt als pkw zum beispiel im
september 2017 auf der a 67 bei
darmstadt ein polnischer
kleintransporter war ein verkehrter
richtung auf die autobahn aufgefahren
drei menschen starben
die schweizer axa-versicherung weiß die
sprinter sind ein besonderes sicherheits
bissen wenn es zum unfall kommt dann
sind die folgen des unfalls schwer wenn
die ladung zb in die fahrerkabine hinein
gedrückt wird oder auch weil die masse
hat größer ist als die 3,5 tonnen und
die beschädigungen am gegen fahrzeug
noch größe sind im crashtest hat die
versicherung die ursachen von unfällen
mit kleintransportern untersucht das
volumen bei den lieferbaren ist relativ
groß man kann da relativ viel
reinkriegen doch die masse die ist
beschränkt auf 3,5 tonnen und das führt
dazu dass lieferwagen sehr häufig
überladen sind überladen auch faden und
die fahrer oftmals davon gar nichts
wissen
seit jahren fordern speditions verbände
scharfe gesetze für die kleintransporter
vier jahre lang war dafür alexander
dobrindt zuständig unternommen hat er
nichts wir wollen vom ehemaligen
verkehrsminister wissen warum ein
interview versuch wird vom
pressesprecher abgewimmelt
warum äußert sie sich denn nicht
wir haben ja offiziell angefragt wir
müssen doch nicht immer das gleiche
spiel machen haben das mit den kollegen
in dem frau ihn genauso gehabt später
eine antwort vom verkehrsministerium sie
tags deutschland unterstützt vorschläge
der eu-kommission zur einbeziehung von
fahrzeugen unter 3,5 tonnen in den
anwendungsbereich der regelungen für den
straßengüterverkehr
solche vorschläge gibt es schon seit
jahren umgesetzt wurden sie bisher nie
so geht es weiter dass prekäre leben am
rande der autobahn mit hungerlöhnen für
die fahrer und überladenen
kleintransportern auf deutschen straßen